good morning
[Music]
[Music]
when it's down
louder with crowder is brought to you in
part by production.com
you don't have to be a freeloader your
whole life the good news is that you can
support this show and the fight by
buying some really cool
dot
clothes.com
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
oh it's a good it's a good me too sip no
oh oh yeah i sip two because me two's
back because uh we have a lot to talk
about today first off let me tell you uh
before anything else we're going to be
talking about the border crisis a lot of
people have been saying why haven't you
been covering it because i've been
waiting to see how it unfolds yeah
because we've done segments on the
border crisis quite a bit with you under
trump and how the numbers started sort
of not sort of they absolutely started
increasing i just changed my clothes
right before the show yeah so i'm a
little winded
from changing your clothes
it's a whole thing i gotta change my
clothes well it's surgery but we'll be
talking about the border crisis i think
what's important is for you to
understand kind of what the media has
been telling you what's actually
happening and these are two very
different things
and and why it matters so i know we're
not talking about the border crisis
first and that's kind of the beauty of
what we do with this show is you know
there didn't there wasn't always a
24-hour news cycle in this country you
watched there was a half-hour news you
know three times a day and it was
basically the same thing um so we don't
have to
manufacture a crisis and there is a
border crisis but we don't have to cover
it every day when there's no new
information so
consolidating it and letting you know
look how this affects you and what you
can do and with this it starts with
local politics uh and uh you know if you
live uh in west texas
it's it's it's less paperwork to uh
respect castle doctrine laws so we'll
talk about all this everything you need
to know about the border crisis it'll be
pretty thorough uh and we'll also talk
about chris cuomo grabbing wife's asses
just to be clear it's not like aziz i'm
sorry a bad date you know some me too's
you're like wow okay that doesn't no
this is grabbing a woman a woman's ass
in front of her husband these cuomo
brothers the brothers cuomo are absolute
garbage
just to be clear so we'll talk about all
of that today but gerald a how are you i
am well how are you sir i'm okay a
little when i still have the the sinus
infection going i'd rather be with my
babies that's true oh that's this oh
it's touching well and then
did you ever feel that quarter black
garrett here he's a quarter black uh we
have the 23 me to prove it were you that
way with your first one because
your first play
are you like i just want to be hanging
out with them yeah i love i love my kids
my kids are great i still do that were
you that and dave landa of course the
funniest man on his feet how are you
well thank you good good did you play
with your your kids like neighbors kids
come on no absolutely no 100 percent by
the way
is available on craigslist yes it is uh
well it's it's
been cleaned uh yeah um some
it was a 60 minute black light special
yeah
there's still caution tape around it
um no uh with i would rather be with my
son any time of any day even now oh yeah
yeah and he's six and it's like i would
just we were just talking about playing
nintendo and just yeah it's the i love
hanging out with well i you know the
truth is i don't like my son much well
really no i'm kidding
my my son is one face that's grumpy and
my daughter she's so expressive yeah and
she is taken to i told you about this
believe me wash my hands trim my nails
when i was uh fixing her bib she started
sucking on my finger yeah and she like
brushes her gums with it yeah anyway i
don't to me it's just a door in other
words what people say about i'm not
gonna be that guy show you pictures in
my wallet or pictures of his van it's
everything they say is true and for me
you know it wasn't true at the very
first moment i wasn't like you were
there and you hit my child with your
phone that's no yes wow gerald
dropped his phone on my baby and made
him everybody within the first minute
and i'm interested and joel's like you
want to get a close up
there are no accidents except that is
exactly what happened that is exactly
what happened
well at least you were a butterfingers
with the phone and not the baby it's
true you know what's better than
dropping a baby on your phone yeah
they're resilient silver lining they
bounce the point is those of you who
don't have children or babies everything
they say is true yeah about that where
you're like oh
it really is true it's a whole different
thing you look at them and uh except my
son he's kind of you know
lukewarm i'm just glad i had a a case on
my phone
look heat was that a nerf one otherwise
it's a lot harder the otterbox was
helpful when it fell on your son's head
look you've had surgery he was recently
circumcised i don't think he's not going
to be moody for a little while for a
little while that's true yeah why are
you so moody you just cut off half of my
penis
it's tradition
you don't understand theology and how
you're grafted into the faith but sooner
someday you'll be grateful because it
seems to me before we move on to
anything else it seems to me with women
in the circ we'll talk about it after
that
probably wise
it's a deal breaker only one one way it
seems right there are some people who
are accepting of all of it and there's
someone who are like i'm just not ex i'm
accepting a red mushroom i'm not
accepting of the tree wiener but i don't
know i don't know any woman who's like
circumcised
no well it's well it's usually the women
getting it depending on what country
you're in yes
oh oh come on what facts yeah fats are
offensive they are well hold on to your
butts because today is going to be a
bumpy ride border crisis by the way
bullets fake never happened never and
the guomos uh but before that anyone
else
first off comment anyone out there who
have the babies who have the children
like did you find everything that people
said was was true i was always afraid
that yeah i was like what if i don't
what if i meet them and just like
yeah that's not gonna happen your life
changes you see them you go oh instant
connection see it was an instant
connection for me but it i think i've
connected more with the daughter because
she's so she's so experienced that's
common for guys though until they can
like do stuff to interact we don't
connect like moms do yeah they love
drugs running into their veins
i haven't met mine i just went to get
cigarettes
i think about them every once in a while
you know you know
it's the interactive like it's it's the
interactivity sooner or later they got
to earn their keep
whenever somebody you guys are cold
would hand me a baby or try to hand me a
baby like don't you want to hold my kid
i'd be like no no it's like the most
expensive vase yeah yeah
i don't go into william sonoma for the
exact same reason right yeah i don't
know steven wouldn't hold my child no i
it's not out of disrespect it's just
like if something happens i like i don't
know
i don't want to be on the uh the six
o'clock news see again that's it it used
to be six o'clock news now there you go
always news but now yeah the second
although i had my baby i was like oh i
like i held them i wanted like all of a
sudden it was a part of me like
something switched in an instant that i
didn't have before yeah so babies are
good there you go babies are good for
the soul
uh they're expensive i don't think so oh
absolutely not no you should know i'm
one in town i think dave's mike is a
little hot today i don't know he's a
little loud uh not you it's the mic as
hot no i understand okay i'll shut up no
no not shut up i'm not shut up
all this baby talk people must be
thrilled like can you talk about the
haitians
well they have babies too
that's half the problem
they have a lot of kids for sale so i'm
saying have more babies man oh geez
how much is that haitian in the window
no it's a true look that we'll also talk
about this is something people don't
understand they think they're being
compassionate when they're talking about
the open borders do you have any idea
how much sex trafficking goes on there
oh that obviously would be stopped if
there was a wall that obviously would be
it's not compassionate to people who are
coming here illegally we'll get into the
asylum claim all that but this is a
perfect example of well-intended people
hurting folks if you support open
borders it will result in more child sex
trafficking we'll have the stats a
little later on and approve it but first
uh peta
recently released a clip and if you have
children they shouldn't watch this after
all that nice baby talk and i'm gonna go
to these degenerates at peta
who would have thought that vegans would
be degenerates
weird
weird surprise
here's their ad promoting veganism
because of course
people listening on audio it's
they're fondling fruit and
vegetables in a sexual manner
claiming that fruits and vegetables
enhance your sex life a very specific
thing that men can't find yes
not that one
is that lizzo it's almost over
peter if you think that's bad wait till
we go to mug club later it gets worse it
gets so much worse that's so terrible
yeah what do you
i've i was just laughing i i was just
envisioning a hole just drilled in a
melon
anybody seen that video that's the male
audience on that one
i speak for peta jason biggs oh
they had alicia silverstone uh naked in
times square
as one of their ads i'm sorry what yeah
look no i agreed with it
that one that was dave went vegan for a
week after and then there was an amber
alert on all our phones for alicia
silverstone
and i looked up and i was like yeah i
think i'll cut out red meat for a while
yeah but yeah that makes some sense here
this this just makes me want to just
actually just eat a cow raw yeah in
front of someone who loves this yeah
just for spike
no no that they hate meat meat is
disgusting right that's absolutely
that's why you're you're vegan burgers
in no way try to recreate exactly what
was delicious in the first place it's an
impossible burger yeah because it's
impossible to match the taste with
crappy plants yes it is
and it's a bunch of processed crap
anyway so again my question before we go
into the border crisis thing how do you
how do you think we could have avoided
this what do you think when you i i
think it's one of those issues where it
pays i don't i hate the term reductive
yeah because that's sort of as comedians
our whole goal is to be reductive but
really i look at it as distillation when
you distill information what are you
doing you're distilling it to the most
pure uh information that needs to be
provided facts data and then your
opinion maybe some enlightening uh or
insightful ways to look at these facts
and data but
it's not that complicated no countries
have borders i want a revolving door
except with no entrance on our side just
revolves you right back into the kitchen
just a rubber band you come in
back out what the hell is i'm back here
now should i just more of a spring yeah
you can come in legally but if you try
illegal there's the door right that's
also not a trap
walk through the tsa metal detector you
hit a button and a spring
yeah what if we can throw back once we
don't want then i'm fine with it here's
aoc bring over whoever yeah let's trade
it's like ah we're gonna catapult you
that's actually a trebuchet i don't know
the nomenclature for the difference
i think it's a distance a leverage thing
i don't know the point is bucky yeah
it'd be like baseball cards in the 80s
except with human beings oh geez
can we pull that minecraft you played
with the donald trump's building the
wall that was the most hilarious thing
i've ever seen
okay hilarious so here's something else
i want to talk about hey uh look with
the vaccine before we move on there's
some more celebrity breakthrough cases
i'm going to give you some examples all
references available the link in the
description letters
i don't know when we stop calling it a
breakthrough case when it's like a
majority of the cases
here's the you want to know how you
don't try and i'm not saying that i
think this is my stance in the vaccine
it makes sense for some old people it
makes sense absolutely for people who
are in high risk
but
the truth is people are mad that they
took a vaccine that isn't that effective
are you vaccinated against
measles mumps rubella everyone here yes
how often have you gone into a
restaurant and asked them their policy
on mandating measles
rubella no because the vaccine works
you're not concerned about it you're
like that's not that well i'm vaccinated
you don't trust the vaccine and so
you're mad at everybody else but we'll
give you some examples here breakthrough
cases this happened on friday and i
couldn't breathe i was laughing so hard
uh well let's just show on the view live
before kamala harris is coming on to the
view and then she has to call him from
like a green room she has to call him
for like satellite uplink like right
yeah from yes from washington dc with
just three rooms away yes
uh
two view members tested positive i don't
know how they were they testing them
before they went on air like uh should
we yeah you know enjoy here should we uh
should we like wait for the results now
go out you'll be fine so then on air two
view hosts test positive here you go
gosh
two of you to step off for a second okay
and and and uh and we're gonna bring it
back later
yes and we'll tell you why more
information later it's a tease we'll
tell you why in a couple of minutes
so shall i introduce the vice president
yes
okay
so vice president
no no okay shall we dance let's do a tap
dance
so quick on your
feet story any minute now what happened
is that uh sunny and anna both
apparently tested positive for covid no
matter how hard we try uh these things
happen they probably have a breakthrough
case and they'll be okay i'm sure
because they're both vaccinated up the
wazoo you know a lot of vaccines uh okay
first it might be a breakthrough case uh
do you mean by definition yes it
absolutely is if they're vaccinated it's
a breakthrough i'm sitting here watching
this school and people try to tell you
it's very rare but that's
that's 33 of the view that is a third of
the view that just got kicked off
live on air 33
of the view i'm not too offended by that
really that's not that's not that
actually that's like a good start more
often i'll be honest the one in the
black and white suit may not come back
it seemed kind of staged though they
were like totally fine there was no
shock and it was like oh it's a tease
for later i'm like what
if they were positive why'd you let them
go out i see an empty pantsuit by the
campfire yes
oh yeah there's a rapid test done what
nine minutes before that
show and by the way this is not uncommon
just to be clear okay i'll give you the
anecdotal and then the empirical there's
so and this this is one thing you guys
should know if you try to search
celebrities with covid you go to all of
these mainstream websites whether it's
nbc abc people they always try to
obviously cover up whether the person
was vaccinated or not you have to dig
several pages deep sometimes it required
me to confirm through instagram comment
replies let me just give you a few
examples there are hundreds hundreds of
examples just a few people say oh it
must be pretty rare for the vaccine to
get cases you've got oscar de la hoya
chris rock bill these are all
celebrities who are vaccinated by the
way chris rock bill maher bendy uh what
bendy wendy williams hillary duff she
got benny when she had the stroke on her
hillary duff jesse jackson kevin
connolly and his daughter both paul
staley and gene simmons from kiss we
were spared peter chris corey tallow
from slipknot barry sanders melissa joan
hart pierce morgan nine members of the
new york yankees eleven congressman
colin quinn look this is there's so many
i mean i could just all of these people
float
explain that
no and colin quinn was vaccinated and
it's his second time getting covet
actually oh wow right yeah and i i don't
know i won't get into that because we
don't have you can't have accurate data
on this no that's the problem people
said well the vaccine and i get it the
goal posts have changed the vaccine
reduces your chance of going to the
hospital or dying okay hold on a second
two percent two percent is the entire
population who end up getting
hospitalized you can find numbers as
high as five numbers as low as one
pretty agreed upon two percent bill
maher was talking about it that includes
89 year olds that include life
expectancy is about the same as the
average covid death so what's the number
for people like us in our 30s and our
20s going to the hospital it's 2 total
let's say could it be 1 could it be 0.5
those numbers don't exist if you have
them comment below it's very hard to
find that but if the vaccine reduces
your chance of hospitalization from one
percent or point five percent to point
four percent at what point do you say
hey it's not anti-scientific for a
thirty-year-old male or female to say no
long-term studies that's by definition i
don't know if the risk is worth the
reward when there's less than a one
percent chance of me being hospitalized
and you see the cackling broads on the
view test positive anyway
and why why are you keeping the numbers
away from us breakthrough cases i i
think i understand why you don't want us
to see how many cases there really are
well the cdc doesn't track a lot of
breakthrough kids they don't unless you
go to the hospital or unless you die but
that's the thing they track every single
other case that is reported but this one
they're like throw it away so they only
have the data of people in the hospitals
people who are potentially and even then
they haven't tracked all of them uh so
you have in israel 59 of those
hospitalized with covid were vaccinated
right these numbers were through
mid-summer yeah uh and fi the pfizer
vaccine this was from mayo 50 000 people
in these studies the pfizer vaccine was
only 42 effective against the delta
variant in july that's a pretty big
sample group it was separated for age
for race for gender and
okay at one point people go you know
what this isn't what we were sold this
is not like other vaccines namely
because we change the definition it's
not an immunization yes which is why joy
behar goes there they're vaccinated up
to the wazoo it's like doesn't that
bother you that they have the disease
might be a problem
up the wazoo and you have to take them
out of the room yeah exactly for the
person who ends up calling in through
skype
wasn't even in the room at that point
kamala harris boy she sucks
you know what else to the view there
such morons this happened last week i
don't have a clip i'm sure we can
probably pull it later from mug club
they were talking about the tax increase
that uh uh uh
former professor former vice president
joe biden is you know by the way i
haven't heard anyone else say this
who's going to be paying more in taxes
above 400 thousand what is the
presidential salary could it be more
transparent right uh he's like john
loves that uh yeah
uh everyone making over four hundred
thousand that's the ticket yeah see
where's obama was president yes it was
over two hundred fifty thousand guess
what the vp salary was i think they're
just using him as a standard barely
what does joe mike he's
you know he he can't afford it
you've seen what he's given to charity
almost done joe how about 400 000 in one
dollar i don't think so
no no no no strike it down yeah no and
whoopi goldberg was on air talking about
the taxes i i'll we'll find a clip later
you guys can show me she was dumbfounded
again she didn't do the research before
being on air she's sitting there she's
going now i don't know if i looked at
the i look at the bottom tax increases
and it's anybody making over four
hundred thousand that's crazy that's not
rich that's upper middle class i'm like
you didn't know this until you got on
air
it's not because you're a woman it's
because you're stupid hold on that's
upper middle class yeah well she's just
pretty rigid which is pretty rich but
she was saying she thought it was you
know the one percent making millions she
realizes it's going to affect her i was
looking it's any joint household making
over 400 thousand this is we need to
know these people are not rich like
really how much do you make there well
yeah it's just funny because yeah whoopi
goldberg doesn't think she's rich
she's whoopi i make 10 million dollars
and let me tell you that is not rich the
point is she didn't know until she went
on air yeah exactly these people are
journalists informed oh
that's not a bad whoopee by the way no
that's pretty good whoopee ah yeah i
have to talk about things i don't know
about it's crazy it's it's crazy child
my dog actually looks like whoopi
goldberg in the 80s so does predator
yeah
that's true
hold on i have to go hunt with heat
seeking technology
[Laughter]
so just camouflaging in a tree want some
candy
ugly mud so uh billy eilish this is
another news before we get to the
cuomo's and then border crisis billy
eilish lost a hundred thousand followers
after posting this photo of her in a
corset
do you have the picture there overlay s
we don't have the picture but we have
the the quote oh we have the quote
why does she take down the picture
i'm not sure i could check okay let's
even grab the picture behind the picture
yeah if we're going to talk about
someone's boobs yeah we got to show the
boots right
somebody pull up the picture that's a
good thing yeah she uh she this is the
she's the producers here sorry we have
two people who called in sick i guess
they felt like this is a story about
billy eilish's boobs let's pull a quote
well i think they pulled the picture
they were having a problem getting it
like sent to us yeah you mean half of
our producers are gay is that what it is
so they have a filter on their computer
where they're like i just don't see
boobs
and then they spell it b e e w b s cubes
e w yeah so eilish uh called the
incident dehumanizing and said that she
lost her followers because quote
entirely because people are scared
of big
boobs uh
that goes against everything that i've
known about yeah if you've been
regarding your next boobs ever
especially on instagram yeah especially
right she lost
they're saying it's about soccer counts
well well that's so the investigation
revealed that uh there they are yeah
there you go she said she lost a hundred
thousand followers because of that
picture
uh wow
that's weird people are scared of big by
the way an investigation did reveal that
she did lose followers but nine ninety
nine thousand nine hundred and ninety
nine were actually yeah they were
actually just sock accounts of uh this
man
[Applause]
the other ones were finished in a sock
account
well just look at her though it really
is the opposite of her entire image it's
like hey yeah that uh that girl has been
carving pentagrams into her desk oh
she's got a nice pair of fat naturals
that's kind of weird
her and of course is like is like ali
sheety from the breakfast club in a prom
queen sash it just doesn't make sense
her fans weren't disappointed in her
boobs they were just disappointed they
weren't covered in track marts
you you really you just you really can't
change your likeness when you spent your
entire career looking like someone who
folds
slipknot shirts at hop top hot tub
rainbow shirts like that's just my thing
i really like my chemical romance you
suck yeah i just like what part my
hair's green and i'm sad
yeah she just looks like a cutter yeah
and that's what you come to and then she
came out i'm marilyn monroe now yes by
the way is a pronounced eyelash cause
i've been confused for two years is it
is it it looks like eyelash is it
stylish
i don't know i was focusing on her boobs
yeah i was you could never see him she
was always wearing a hot topic
sweatshirt was distracted
by the way you can follow me speaking of
instagram you can follow me uh on the
instagram and i guess tick tock uh over
there's a lot of stuff that doesn't uh
have to do with the show if you're a
commie and the best thing is if you
watch hit the notification bell
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot but
best ways just tune in monday through
thursday live 10 a.m eastern yeah but
you can hit that little bell so you get
the notification subscriptions mean
nothing now on youtube they keep
changing it because you know they want
to auto play seth meyer's crap yeah the
algorithm did you ever hear their bond
song sorry verb song
billy eilish oh i don't know adele's the
best bonsai adele was great was great
and even though it wasn't a very good uh
tom jones thunderball was fantastic
absolutely yeah 100 i don't know the
billionaires no billy ellis is boxing
for the news just like
i wanna put the gun in my mouth
i don't want it she's so depressing
i was talking to a friend about this and
he's like gerald she's super i was like
she's gonna go like she's so depressing
who listens she goes he's got a billion
plays and my wife is like so and he goes
that's a million that's a million a
thousand million plays i'm like did you
just math explain what a billion is to
my wife yeah it happens yeah you kick
his ass yeah i did yeah good you should
i throw him in the lake i don't think he
got out you don't mathsplain you don't
last lane
my wife
she wanted want to be massable and two
she would have gone to the stem field
but she doesn't just like women
statistically don't so that's why they
have slots open for them and uh
good luck with your anesthesiologist
um
if i get if i'm getting put under by a
woman when i'm going there i'm like oh
you weren't a diversity stem uh stem
acts acceptance until stanford stop it i
like to hear a good indian accent and a
doctor and i go i'm in good hands
bangladeshi
i don't know the difference so um i'm
not one
country i don't have a topographical map
of that you don't need one continent
so
this is look and speaking of kicking
asses
if a man grabs your wife's ass in front
of you i mean reaches cups grabs
first off it should never happen ever
ever but especially if it just so
happens to be caught by a husband which
is exactly what chris cuomo did comment
below if you're a husband or if you're a
woman if you think there just needs to
be an ass kicking if either of you did
that to my wife i'd just think well i'm
sorry there's nothing i can do it must
be you forced me to do this to you so
chris cuomo was accused by former boss
shelly ross of grabbing her buttocks at
a party yeah um
and it's documented he he even said an
email now that i think of it i am
ashamed and the text
so she said he grabbed my buttock right
when he greeted me and said now that i
don't work for you anymore because
you're not my boss i can do this and she
said no you can't and her husband was
right there yeah he watched the whole
thing caught the whole thing and uh he
in an email which by the way if you
sexually assault a woman which you
should never do
don't
talk about it in an email you wrote it
down it's the first lesson of being a
perverted creep cuomo
spacey's just shaking his head so he he
wrote an email
though my hearty greeting was a function
of being glad to see you
christian slater got arrested for a kind
of similar act though born of alleged
negative intent and a husband i can
empathize empathiz empathize with not
liking to see my wife patted as such so
pass along my apology to your good and
noble husband and i apologize to you as
well for even putting you in such a
situation okay it's a couple of things
here first off it's not that he just
grabbed a woman's butt at that this is
not something that just happens out of
the blue how many incidents had to
happen leading up to this i tell you
this as a man where none of his friends
none of his uh his colleagues his
confidant and his male circle thought
there should be any accountability
whatsoever like hey man you know you got
to stop you got to stop groping women
this is a man who lives in a bubble just
like his brother and fears no
accountability and more insulting than
all is they try and say oh it's
tradition or they try to say oh it's uh
because we're italian you know that was
something that his brother said yeah and
uh let me tell you this i'm french
canadian okay what's what are you doing
what are you what are you oh
oh cuomo brother what do you think
no don't stop grabbing the asses mario
cuomo it's like asking bread not to want
to be toast what does that even mean no
it's like watermelon saying no pits no
no
no no culture demands that you grab stop
you can't grow up yo stop driving
afterwards
hey hey hello hey cuomo come on mario
como stop grabbing asses no more
come on
jeez i told him to not grab asses
well that's what mario cuomo seems to do
all the time i he's doing the opposite
of what i asked and his brother fredo
cuomo can be even worse that's a slur oh
good thing i'm half italian
it's a slur against lesser brothers yes
it's a slur against you and the dylan
brother from entourage really yes yeah
that's true the lesser dylan the lesser
you had to remind me this was the cnn
cuomo this is not the governor of cuomo
right we were talking about this
yesterday i was like i did something
else you're like no it's the other guy
it's the rapist it's the brothers
so here's here's just to give you an
idea so this happened with chris cuomo
he should absolutely be fired by the me
too standards uh but his brother what
did his brother do his brother uh
grabbed anna rooch's rut's face at a
wedding asked if he could kiss her
charlotte bennett said that uh cuomo
asked her this is the brother if she had
sex with older men it was nogamous uh
virginia lemiatus uh was reportedly
touched inappropriately when cuomo ran
his fingers across her chest i'd say
that's inappropriate
yeah uh and of course cuomo asked
lindsay boylan to play strip poker
kissed her on the lips and went out of
his way to touch her lower back arms and
legs and finally there was also this
little known case where andrew took a
date to the movies and cut a hole in the
bottom of his bowl of spaghetti this is
when the media yeah see that's that's
takes a lot of work the old mickey
rourke
diner uh mickey rourke uh thing this the
cuomo brothers are just okay let's go
all right mario what are you doing come
on let me try that no try what stop no
we like no you get to meet dogs yeah no
grab a diaper that's not an italian no
no no no no no not an italian thing
no it's not a call oh
stop oh that's wrong
it's my fault it's how i'm driving your
phone it's not your fault
that's enough hey hey mario cuomo look
at me
stop grabbing asses
okay
sometimes you have to be stern dave hey
dave yeah i know you've seen a lot of
screwed up [ __ ] yes
it's not your fault yeah yeah it is it's
not your fault hey look at me what
it's not your fault shut up
it's not your fault
so this is what this is the damage you
do cuomo's brothers this is this is what
happens horrible
i kind of liked it
[Laughter]
said no woman cuomo
just the lack of tact he has is more
upsetting than the violations itself
oh no that didn't happen
doesn't it feel like a power move
like trying to be like yes it does like
it like basically
it's the cuomo brothers and what happens
in san quentin yeah like those are the
two places this kind of behavior
happened like we were just grabbing
someone's ass like your wife is mine
yeah
mind if we dance with your dates
no go ahead sir
otis my man
cuomo my man this is just so look just
to be clear the cuomo brothers are
absolute garbage and the media knew this
for a very long time and i don't think
they're rapists to be clear but this is
this is beyond this is absolutely sexual
harassment yes yes and women do deserve
to
feel as though they're not going to have
their asses or chest grabbed in the
workplace i try to create a culture here
uh cuomo brothers not withstanding not
grabbing women's asses that's good it
may not be popular
but i always say don't grab women's
privates against their will that is i
appreciate that thank you yes yes indeed
it may not be popular to say no i don't
care whoever gets mad at me for saying
this
that's what that's my belief
common sense i always say the third no
means no
yeah for sure yeah that one's it doesn't
mean you shouldn't keep trying a little
no you got to give him a chance to play
it cool there's a game yeah well yes
the game is not you can't fire me
anymore so now i can do whatever i want
which is what cuomo said to her
essentially but stay you know and the
media the media only when it became
undeniable right they covered up and
this is the same thing i think he should
have been kicked out for you know
killing old people well that was his
brother but yeah his brother the other
queen and then his brother and then the
other the lesser cuomo not covering it
uh but it's the same thing what do you
think they're going to do with whitmer
look we all know that there's been a
record number of senior citizens in
michigan the governor but of course
because she's a woman she's likely not
sexually harassing anybody
and she seems like she would be a second
take
that's not all it's not always true but
she doesn't seem she seems like a like
uh like she could go a long spell like a
sex camel oh jesus like she does not
need it yes she is no she's not careful
she's feeding off the blood of the young
yeah that's actually indeed she just
puts poddlings in the chair
so oh yeah i feel like a like a tail
would come out like splice yes just take
your soul
it's like night crawler
do you think that you but you know that
uh quilt cuomo made of masks that we're
saying oh yeah you know forgiven for
children and that he sewed it together
to make do you think he had holes in
them pinning them against a corkboard
yeah you think he had sex on it what do
you think yeah probably yeah definitely
he's like i'm gonna make a mask sex
quilt those he just used them as uh sex
thongs that's right hey look
this thing's not getting the kovids you
like it
people keep mailing me sexy underwear
yeah those are masks you idiots ah only
fit if the if the mask fits
you must
what does that mean i don't know but
look at it hey call my brothers and the
media is complicit it means it gets off
yeah
just like so you have both both cuomo
brothers
and now it's something let's go to the
border crisis the media of course has
been complicit this is something where
they have lied to you and this affects
you directly as an american citizen and
let me just cut this off with the past
where people try and say look look
it's not a it's not a race thing any
more than mexico's southern borders are
racing any more than any other country
having a border is a race thing as a
matter of fact we're talking about the
united states having a a protected
border it's clearly less of a race thing
than other homogenous countries okay
look now you're saying it's racist
against haitians this is an isolated
incident where before this people would
say donald trump was racist against
mexicans the beauty of the wall it's
it's it's an inanimate object it doesn't
matter doesn't matter your opinion you
rebound off of it
so the border crisis look everyone's
talking about this uh they've been
trying to cover the media covered that
people are being whipped not true i'll
show you proof afterwards um
who is running the show though with this
because a lot of people think that biden
is a shell of his former self which is
an insult to shells of their former
selves
insult to turtles
oh man
so most of you likely never seen this
clip of obama i think like who's running
the show but here's actually what the
producers found november 30th 2020 uh
call it a hunch i said this before i i
uh
people would ask me
knowing what you know now do you wish
like you had a sec a third term
um
and i i used to say
you know what if if i could make an
arrangement where
um
i had a i had a uh stand in a front man
or front woman and and they had an ear
piece in and i was just in my basement
in my sweats
looking through the
stuff and then i could sort of deliver
the lines but somebody else was
uh doing all the talking and ceremony
i'd be fine with that because i found
the work fascinating
like someone like kamala harris no
no no no she's too strong-willed she
doesn't even like promo cuomo grab her
ass uh so right now they're talking on
cnn about really quickly and this does
obviously the border crisis will go to
this how the murder rate in the u.s
jumped nearly 30 percent in 2020. and of
course they're trying
to they're trying to blame this on
donald trump no no it was the riots
there was stuff going on well look at
the murder rates and where they took
place they took place in entirely blue
cities blue cities where they've had
free reign for
decades yeah decades and by the way the
murder rate is also going up in 2021. so
this is important to note crime
crime was going on a downward trend and
to be fair with all presidents crime was
was trending downward bill clinton
george w bush yeah obama uh then it went
up in the last year of obama went
started trending downward a little bit
again and then of course we had the
riots which were spurred on where kamala
hara said do not stop continue continue
rioting in the streets and uh now we're
going to add you know who knows a couple
million illegal immigrants who come from
third world war-torn countries into the
mix
so things are getting better this will
be fun let me give you some of these
numbers here uh comparing biden versus
trump on the border because i think you
need some context to understand a lot of
people need to go oh actually there was
this number of border crossings under
donald trump well if you just hear
number without context what's the
increase what's the decrease what's
going on how does this change your
day-to-day life okay there are over 1.5
million encounters with customs and
border protection in 2021 that's over 6
000 per day
that's a lot
uh retired border patrol chief rodney
scott said nearly 53 percent are granted
title 42 exemption and release back in
the united states the border encounters
we're talking about customs and border
patrol highest rate in the last 21 years
wow objectively that's from pew research
all the sources references available at
largecry.com last uh friday uh secretary
mayorkas and by the way whenever i watch
these clips i get confused i think it's
i think it's jeff bezos
it does but rich i guess rich evil
bastards who want to live forever they
will kind of bleed together after a
while uh he told ron johnson that he uh
we just gave you the numbers majorca
said he didn't know how many illegal
immigrants are released and the media
was like oh i guess we don't know yeah
no need to fact check i just provided
the information the mayor
here or may yeah mayorka sorry secretary
mayorkas secretary
jeff bezos clone
he's another freaking evil clone doesn't
know again 1.3 million people
how many people have been returned
how many people are being detained how
many people have been dispersed to all
points around america six thousand a day
uh senator i would be pleased to provide
you with that debt i want them now six
thousand a day fifty three thousand a
senator are allowed enough to have that
debt why not
why don't you have that basic
information
senator i want to be accurate in the in
the info i'm looking for ballpark
figures
is it about half have we dispersed about
half of that are we up to about 600 000
people we dispersed senator these are
the tools that we employ
uh we use the title 42 authority that is
the public health authority
empowered by the centers for disease
control
53 so i'm hearing that you are now under
title 42 to the fullest in the united
states you've got
40 50
of people even apprehended under title
42 that are not being returned is that
accurate that that is that is actually
inaccurate okay so what what is the okay
so obviously you're not saying that
senator would you care to let the
witness finish an answer he's not
answering right
i actually want to answer my question
does that look like a creepy utopian
future yeah after that clip or wren
fields get me the number 142 exemptions
it burns i mean
i'm i'm lex luthor yes
it does look like every super it's
voldemort like it's it's all these same
people they all look like baseball so
direct comparison this is like you just
he pointed out you were very very
various two doctors yes he goes oh those
that's wrong okay what's right this is
and this is the problem too with we're
going to do a rebuttal to john oliver in
the voting laws tomorrow people on the
left have the luxury of just going oh
that's wrong well what's the number wow
uh you're just crazy trust the science
what's the science uh you're just crazy
uh how about we have a
hate speech they don't want a debate
they don't want to have a conversation
and they sit because they have a
complicit media because of a complete
entertainment industry they have the
luxury of never having to provide you
with information we make all of our
references available link in the
description now i ask you guys to double
check it and you guys sometimes correct
things in the comments section oh
correction last week i think i said 86
of black americans wanted at least as
much police presence uh or more than
they have now i think it was 81. there
you go there you go 81. i said 80
something i said 86 i was wrong by 5
percent doesn't change the fact that
whoopi goldberg blacks don't want any
more cops in the neighborhood child so
the spirit i would argue was correct
so the numbers 6 000 a day 52 are
exempted uh record high in 21 years okay
what do we have under donald trump we
had a record low of 832 interactions at
the border per day in 2017. um we had a
total of 33 percent donald trump's
interactions
were a total 33 percent of that that of
bidens
just to be clear so about that's the
same number as women who test positive
on the view a third
yes
a third of the illegal crossings and
interactions and uh 89 percent were
expelled in november 2020 versus only 47
percent in july 2021 so you have oh wow
you have a multiple of people who are
coming here illegally why because
they're incentivized because they think
that they can come on through yes and
that they won't be sent back you have a
several time multiple of them being sent
into the united states
in many cases no questions asked or very
few questions asked and of course you
have a multiple of uh stress pressure on
those who are border patrol agents just
to be clear when they say you're not
supporting the cops because of the
capitol police uh what about all of the
officers at the border
hmm well and also at least we don't have
donald trump's mean kind of scary racial
policy yeah having a border wall and
that's what they said on this sunday i'm
forgetting the name of the show meet the
press right they were talking on meet
the press and they're like at least we
got rid of donald trump like do you
understand by getting rid of donald
trump's forceful you're going back to
your country no matter what if you don't
come here legally do you understand what
you've done now yeah you've done this
you've done exactly that we have to
cover this story because of that well
let me be really clear too it's it's now
the optics are getting bad enough so
finally the biden administration it's
all run by polls it's all run by what
they think they can get away with yes
uh
he said that uh the del rio camp or at
least ordered the by administration to
be cleared out because of quote bad
optics this is from a dhs official the
biden administration wants those people
out from under that bridge so they can't
be seen anymore it's an optics thing
then there was a black lives matter
protest was scheduled to take place near
the bridge this past weekend really they
said they don't want them all riled up
at the time of blm protest what do you
mean by them uh what do you mean by you
people
yeah what do you mean by protest the
whole thing confuses me i'm very
confused and they this has been going on
for a long time the federal aviation
administration banned drones from flying
over the border yeah because they showed
us what was going on oh gosh please
don't actually show us what's happening
look over here biden doesn't understand
the need for drones if they're not
killing innocent families oh no they're
just for that yeah
come on it's vertical alignment you
can't be using the drones for pictures
so they kill kids with them huh there's
zero zero children
children are killed guess what they were
like hey sir there are drones at the
border ah
killing haitians no taking pictures come
on
how does their hair smell
bring them to me so this is something
they fox was allowed to do this fox news
they had this drone going on for a while
again this is a lack of transparency we
just gave you the numbers the body
administration is concerned with ooh
people don't like it people don't like
what's going on at the border right now
so we better get rid of them for optics
and have the media go out and lie and by
the way let's ban anyone when people
talked about donald trump wanting to ban
press he didn't like because he would
make fun of them no this is an
administration that very often actually
put shackles on members of the press we
talked about that a few weeks ago uh it
took texas the local uh texas law
enforcement to be clear this is where
local politics is very important in
border states they had to get a
helicopter to carry a fox reporter to
get these videos out guys good afternoon
to you this is a wild situation to see
from the air we reported earlier that
the faa grounded our fox news drones we
cannot fly those well the troopers with
texas dps are kind enough to let us go
up in their helicopter with them to get
a look at the situation at this bridge
right now take over 11 000 mike mexico
into del rio right here and they are
waiting underneath the international
bridge waiting to be processed by border
patrol look at the massive people down
there okay uh and by the way that uh
secretary ericos he uh told fox news
that there were at least 12 000
who were released uh the haitians over
the past few weeks so you know if he
said 12 000. uh times that by
quite a few well and if i'm if i'm not
mistaken it's of about 15 to 20 thousand
yeah it's a 700 well half or above were
released and you know what the excuse
was not going to stay here very long
yeah that was it
sorry what i i kid you not yeah how long
does it take for them to spread uh kovad
to members of the view yeah i don't know
i think a couple of weeks they'll be
gone
and i think it was somewhere and i don't
want to miss quote so just so i don't
get fact checked it's somewhere between
like 40 and 60 of those people that are
released that are supposed to come back
for a court date so that they could you
know see one it takes six months to a
couple of years for that court date to
happen and two forty to sixty percent
just don't show oh really it's the other
system they'll come people this is like
coming back to me i didn't think i mean
people who are here illegally and can't
be tracked no act without accountability
it's almost like they might go to the
emergency room and skip out on the bill
anyone who would flee their own country
could be a flight risk no i don't know
no no they fled their own country
through several other yeah
that's my point is they're good at
leaving yes
still waiting on him
i'm getting a pack of cigarettes
and no you're not
that's good with coveton court
do you know how i know that you're not
getting a pack of cigarettes from the
convenience store because we have no
store
there's no by the way some people got
offended on twitter where i said that uh
you know the unite that haiti is an
inferior country to the united states
and look i understand cause some people
i don't understand how you can argue
that that the united states is not a
superior country but then also that it's
a human right to be a citizen here
why unless there's something about this
when i said inferior i want to clarify i
was taken out of context when i say that
haiti is inferior to the united states
i i don't mean this at all you meant
genetically well no what i what i mean
is when i say that haiti is inferior
seriously when i say hades and fear of
the united states what i mean is
inhabitability uh uh cost of living gdp
uh inventions uh uh uh benefits to the
world at large the rest of society
creating a functional economy human
rights civil rights that's all i i just
want to be clear
what i meant one life expectancy other
than that totally equal yes other than
that
different
but equal how dare you so uh then you
also saw the pictures of horses and
whips
uh that was what the media tried to
cover you guys
yeah they don't want to give you these
numbers
um
so what happened is even it went up to
the president you had saki you had uh
biden he had harris condemning
this is the point you can't rely on the
media to be honest
but you don't think that former vice
president joe biden and vice president
kamala harris you don't think they have
the ability to figure out if this is a
real story or not
we can figure it out with
researchers me and ones who don't even
pull pictures of billy eilish's boobs
and you and you mean to tell me that the
former vice president came here they are
condemning our officers doing their job
on a story they know to be fake the
secretary also conveyed to civil rights
leaders earlier this morning that we
would no longer be using horses in del
rio what i saw because they're effective
who gives a crap about horses those
individuals on horseback give those
haitians some zyrtec send them on their
way the way they were is horrible
and i fully support what is happening
right now which is a thorough
investigation into exactly what is going
on there and we really have to do a lot
more to recognize that as a member of
the western hemisphere
we've got to support some very basic
needs that the people of haiti have to
see people treat it like they did horses
barely running over people being
strapped
it's outrageous i promise you those
people will pay
they will be an investigation underway
now and there will be consequences
there will be consequences it's an
embarrassment but it's beyond an
embarrassment it's dangerous it's wrong
it sends the wrong message around the
world and if any of those things were
true
you still wouldn't really have a point
but he had just been watching a
spaghetti western yeah yeah no idea i
was watching you know the rifleman how
has his lever action so fast huh what
this is didn't we the semi-automatic
wrong message fired it in the sky no if
any of that were true if any of that
were true sure my question to you is
again comment below what do you think
do you think that these people meaning
the administration don't have the
ability to conduct a simple fact check
they weren't whipping anybody they
weren't running them over with horses
and i don't understand why horses are
relevant if it's a horse or a
four-wheeler the allergies have nothing
to do with it this is them right here is
video proof that no one was being
whipped
just trying to get in here saying no
grab it i'm saying hey stop breaking the
law
stop breaking the wall
anyway the video goes on you can just
that just that that's all it is that was
it now what you thought were whipped
like hey
and then can i come in and the horse is
like nay
you know what they were they were reigns
yeah so we're supposed to believe that
everyone in this administration doesn't
know the difference between whipping
somebody in reigns and again they don't
know the difference between 800 uh
border crossings or interactions today
folks a thousand right by the way you
know what they do with those right they
they sometimes will hit the horse so the
horse knows to go yeah right and it's
not cruel to the horse it's just like oh
i'm going this way okay good just to be
clear this is the asylum claim i
actually would argue this canadians have
more of a claim to asylum because
pastors have been jailed for practicing
their faith so there's actual religious
persecution these haitian migrants
they're actually coming from chile and
brazil or they settled many of them for
a long time they're not fleeing a
government that's persecuting them
they're fleeing what they believe
so it's not me saying it to be an
inferior country to come to a better
country just because we have better
things and we have a good country which
the left can never acknowledge
except when sort of tacitly
acknowledging the border crisis doesn't
mean that you have a right to asylum hey
yeah but i want that i'm sorry is not a
right to asylum because there are people
here who need that there are people here
who need jobs there are people here who
need who pay into the system who need to
make sure that they still have social
security when they're still here let's
just let's just be clear about that it
is not a claim to asylum asylum means
that you are fleeing a specific
political religious persecution at the
hands of your government these people
just don't like the shitty countries
absolutely and like i said earlier the
country shoppings the reason that i said
that is because for asylum claims you
have to go to the nearest safe country
and safe is kind of this loose term
right i don't know if that's the legal
term that they use but it's like all
right if there's a war going on in the
country next to you as well then you
know safe is a loose term when you're
referring to south america and they have
401ks for kidnapping well exactly but
you don't get to go like haiti first of
all haiti is just kind of in the middle
you've got the united states and you've
got south america you made the wrong
choice to begin with so that's your
fault right if you to come here first if
you've gotten on rafts or something like
that it's a horrible thing but then
maybe your claim is legit but you went
through several countries you don't get
to come to some point and say oh i want
to leave my country oh where would you
like to claim asylum uh canada is kind
of nice i don't know maybe go to uh the
uh the alps do you like do you like
mountains like we can send you over to
europe we can send you to china that's
kind of bad labor policy yeah
like that's not how also not very fond
of the
folks of color in china yeah well i
don't know if you guys know this but uh
racism actually does exist i mean like
real racism outside of the united states
go to singapore see what i'm talking
about ouch um in there yeah it's
speaking of strapping yeah yeah
you spit gum on the sidewalk they came
you in singapore well i like the policy
yeah i i understand well so does biden
because he uses terms like strapping
like it's 1850. he was just referring to
an eight-year-old boy trappings
you know what really pissed me off too
about this is that
everybody else basically said this
reminds me of our our troubled history
here in the united states where horses
were used to ground up slaves and i was
like are you kidding me the most
effective way to keep people from coming
in in the water in the kind of
wilderness is a horse this has nothing
to do with slavery you're just trying to
play the like soft background music and
make everybody go horses races let's see
let's find common ground okay let's make
this uh a more urban roundup of illegal
immigrants send some chrysler uh three
thousands down there okay oh there's
three thousand or two thousand
uh depends uh there's a chrysler 200 and
a 300.
the bigger one that looks like the
bentley i was gonna say the fake bentley
the fake bentley were the cat williams
joker yeah it looked like a chrysler 300
and there's nothing wrong with that
there ain't nothing wrong with that
chrysler 300 ho there's mother
i just realized when i'm watching
catwoman's like well he's just i just
i'm jealous of black i mean like he's
just saying black things oh it's not a
joke he's like and y'all know what i'm
eating mama's giblets my god and yet
just the delivery you don't get it you
don't get it you don't get it with white
there's no white equipment [ __ ]
and [ __ ]
i think the white equivalents like
stephen wright or hedberg where it's
like so white yeah i guess
they're still i find him funny but i
just realized watching his special oh
there's your son just he's just saying
we were discussing this on the phone the
other day it is funny but it's not like
it's well written now that's just honest
so um this is something else what is the
media doing right now well look this is
a sleight of hand right he's p and i
want you to understand what they're
doing going he's prominent right the
numbers 800 something border
interactions a day under trump 21-year
low versus 6000 52 are exempt under this
42 bull crap right right now we just
talked about how 12 000 of the 15 000 so
these no these numbers kind of they ebb
and flow it's most of these people are
being let through the united states yeah
and there is an
exponential increase in people flooding
over the border
and it's very clear from donald trump to
jubai no correlation causation look come
on
800 to 6 000 going on non-stop it's not
a mundane detail michael so what the
media has been doing is trying to
distract you about covet covet covet
covet covet covet when really what
affects you more than a if you're a 30
year old .0 something percent mortality
rate again if you're a 30 year old is
perhaps
the labor force being undercut through
people who are willing to accept third
world wages uh tax-free these are things
that affect you day to day and by the
way just so happens to be a tremendous
voter base if you don't require some
kind of voter id isn't that nice uh so
let's even just go to left
and see what they have to say about the
fact that hey
this is a now we can find common ground
are the
we're talking about cova we're talking
about the border crisis you guys are
talking about covert okay okay look hey
meeting of the minds before ben carson
separates them is skillful are you
vaccing
the illegal immigrants most of these
people that are going into removal
proceedings are being put on either
buses
from del rio
to el paso and laredo or being flown
to tucson with no kovid tested by
testing unless they show symptoms how is
that helping
anybody stop the spread
again we have a protocol and process in
place as it relates to covet in terms of
testing and quarantining and also
vaccines are provided for a range of
migrants by our partner organizations
in the region we fly them there and hope
for the best
say in
laredo texas or el paso or two spear
arizona have to have their chance of
catching covent go by the way everyone
hundreds of miles away there's an open
border
well there certainly is not an open
border if somebody walks yes there is
into the country right across the river
did somebody ask them to see
their vaccination card
well let me explain to you again peter
how are processes i'm going to be really
condescending and not answer questions
as individuals come across the border
and
they are both assessed for whether they
have uh any symptoms if they have
symptoms they are the intention is for
them to be quarantined that is our
process just they're not intended to
stay here for a lengthy period of time
it's not the same thing she just said
they're not intending to stay here for a
lengthy period of time just the weekend
hold on i don't even hold on i don't
even care so hold on their hearing could
take six months to two years to happen
you only test them if they have symptoms
right does this sound like something
we've talked about how do you find out
about symptoms by the way yes well what
do you ask them what do you think is
going to happen these people left haiti
yeah an inferior country to the united
states they left haiti are here by will
of by way of chile and brazil you think
they're going to get to the they're
they're they're you know they're they're
triple geeking out horses to get here
all right all right look look okay
you have a stuffy nose no what do you
think they're going to say yeah but i
thought also that it didn't matter if
you had symptoms that was the whole
thing that we were told every
symptomatic carrier exactly that's how
we're at that's how a third of the view
gets covered oh my gosh so here's what's
crazy to me hollywood is even with that
like only if they have symptoms well how
do you test 25 percent of migraines
scheduled for expedited deportation uh
the flights these are people going to be
deported they tested positive for coving
oh my goodness
25 25
that's a stuff that's almost the same
ratio as women on the view 33 25 a
little quarter not quite a third the
point is that's a lot
it is
it's going to give me a plane yeah
it's going to get worse you said
correlation causation before there are
30 000 they estimate 25 to 30 000 more
haitian migrants on their way will be at
the border within a month if you do the
math 50 to 60 are getting in and voter
id is racist and you have states like
arizona that were one within the margin
of just 10 10 000 votes 20 000 votes hey
remember how we gave you the free stuff
and didn't even stick the swab up your
nose who are you gonna vote for
oh
there you go ah welcome
looks like you are covered free
do i still have to fly on spirit
but you still have to pay 95
for a clutch we'll let you work it off
though
so again we talked about this before you
know it affects you as far as your jobs
it affects you it affects you as far as
look there's a burden on the system and
i'm not saying that all illegal
immigrants
are here to abuse a system here's the
thing too that people need to understand
the difference and
silly
silly libertarians like oh it's a free
market it's not a free market you can't
have open borders when you have a
welfare state you can't have open
borders when you incentivize people to
come to a country where they can use the
emergency room as their basic
as their primary physician where they
can come here and still take advantage
of the system and be on welfare be on
ebt cars they can be paid and not pay
taxes because there's no way to track
them you have it's very very different
you could have
open borders if everybody paid taxes and
if there was no social welfare system
that was being paid into by legal
citizens of this country
there's a very very big difference
that's why the libertarian idea of open
borders don't work
there's a huge difference between when
italian americans came here when jewish
americans when irish americans came here
we didn't have the same kind of bennies
that you do now let's be really clear
about that and once you create that you
either need to do away with it or you
need to have a guest book but how else
does it affect you this isn't this is a
number a sleight of hand that the media
tries to sell you that actually you know
what a few immigrants commit less crime
than american citizens hold on a second
the key word there is illegal immigrants
of course people who migrate here
legally are going to be law abiding
citizens because they had to follow the
law and they understand that they are on
thin ice here if they're in this country
now people who cross the border
illegally commit more crime than the
average american all of these sources
are available at lotterysquare.com i
mean the illegal part's already a crime
it already is but i mean in addition to
that when we're talking about violent
crime so of course people say well just
because of the crossing illegally that
too but all the other crimes that affect
you hold on dave dave listen
no person is illegal dave
that's that's we just all agree uh
except for every person who is an
illegal person here in this country i'm
going to get that tattooed on my lower
back to let everybody know i'm woke yeah
i'm going to upload a picture of your
corset so when you're in prison you'll
know where to go
so we can see my puffy breasts well this
is something that libertarians argue
the left
uh by the way you might want to get that
looked at the left they try to argue
that well you know uh conservatives are
against uh are against uh uh frivolous
spending but look at the they wanted to
spend i think it was i don't know how
much it was 17 billion dollars for a
wall in the tens of billions okay first
off two things that's under the
legitimate purview of government even if
you are the strongest you know strongest
uh federalists to believe in the sort of
legitimate separation of peruvian powers
guess what states cannot be relied upon
unfortunately to protect the entire
border because if texas does a good job
well there's still california right you
have a problem it is a legitimate role
of government of the federal government
to ensure that our borders are secure
but even just looking at a numbers
analysis illegal immigrants don't cost
the american taxpayer 10 billion 20
billion 30 billion 80 billion it sound
like an infomercial now it's not my
first radio
116 billion dollars annually well in
people is the cost of do you know 116
billion to the taxpayer annually uh and
of course uh that that's half my net
worth yes but they might be able to vote
and not pay taxes so that's a wonderful
ploy yeah so if we spend 17 billion
dollars we might be able to knock a very
sizable chunk out of the 116.
right it seems sure it seems like we
should do this and take the other 100
billion and have a party unless you're
doing math like whoopi goldberg well you
have to think about it well sister act
back in the habit
um i wish you'd have stayed there yes
yeah it's just a terrible habit to watch
that movie um and i was saying that a
lot of people argue the uh you know you
i hear this at least uh on the road when
talking to people the christian element
of you should allow anybody we're all
god's kids whatever i think what people
are taking into account with a lot of
this is the people that get a hold of
the kids that come over here right
that's when it turns into sex traffic
drugs all this other stuff like there's
a reason why there has to be order
beyond just like we we should all just
be peaceful
there is true evil going on and that's
why there has to be some kind of rule
and regulation yeah no you're you're
absolutely right we are welcome and we
have a system for people to go through
we do have a system and you know what
the system maybe at some point the
system needs more welcoming yeah maybe
at some point the system needs to be
less welcoming yes it depends on where
we are in this country look there is
nothing
wrong with wanting to take care of your
citizens first haiti should take care of
its citizens first yes the united states
should take care of its citizens first
oh hey you can't do it why is that
it's america's fault really have they
ever gotten it right
at a certain point you also have to
examine the fundamental philosophy of
your economic system and a system that
recognizes inalienable rights in other
words the government's job is to protect
said rights that's its only function
versus the right of the government to
grant and take away rights just make up
rights and that's how you end up with a
place like germany where internet's now
a right in other words sure why why is
it why is it america's job to take care
of people from other countries which by
the way you've said are all equal all
cultures are equal
then no
this is this is a real it's 116 billion
dollars annually um
and what are the effects you talked
about we have some i think you have this
uh uh overlay z uh z or k here uh
reuters bbc and pew thousands of miners
are in uh border patrol custody sexual
assault allegations they're a lack of
clean flow uh clothes food right there
are co there's coveted in their lice
outbreaks uh were you about to say
something yeah i was about to say
haitians what do you want
you have a part of a caribbean island it
could be a tourist paradise destination
and you've turned it into crap yeah what
are you gonna do come here and do the
same thing like it's america's fault
that haiti is the way that it is it's
not like that's what kamala said it's
not like we sent off billions of dollars
in aid it's not like america provided
more help after the earthquakes than any
other country it's not like the the
american uh government the american
military outside of the american
christian evangelical church is the
greatest peacekeeping and charitable
service that exists in the world no it's
our fault it's our it's america's fault
that and when you justify that it's
because of imperialism well imperialism
hold on a second do you understand what
imperial it doesn't cost money you take
the resources yeah you don't go there
and clean up after an earthquake or
natural disaster especially when we have
natural disasters here in the united
states you go and if you're you're in an
imperialist nation you say oh an
earthquake let's pounce guess what any
other empire throughout the history of
mankind take your pick the ottomans the
british empire the romans the greeks any
take your pick genghis khan whatever you
want they would say oh an earthquake
these people can't defend themselves
good we're going to take over haiti
beautiful resources and then there's
this huge swath of land unprotected
canada it's ours now 52 states there you
go and instead we offer them billions of
dollars in aid and are blamed for it not
being enough but you know what you know
what could have prevented all of this
all of this happening at the border the
lice the rape the sex trafficking the uh
unsanitary conditions
big beautiful wall it has to be painted
and the best color to paint it is black
because if you paint it black it's so
hot nobody can even try to climb it and
look it's it's tough to argue with that
logic he's not wrong
and you know who doesn't even disagree
anymore
who the guy who used to hate that and he
tries to avoid the verbiage
chris wallace that the the border patrol
they ought to be able to find a way to
keep people from coming across the
border
build a fence a wall maybe yeah i was
going to say build a fence build a wall
have a have some kind of a gate so they
can't walk across that dam
uh
over the um
rio grande into del rio yeah any any
word oh no but wall
let's go with offense all right you guys
can comment below
you think we need to solve the illegal
just
smash the like button be taking your
chat uh mug club youtube this is gonna
get worse piss off
you